ああああああ
[拍手]
外です
背景は海です無人島です
私あの僻地好きでして
えっといろんな世界の変わったところに行くのが好きなんで7月末に入ったから家
パキスタンというのわたしにとって68番目の国でした
そういうところに来るは大好きなんですが無人島は初めて
ですはい
8私は重要ですいつもはせリフォームラってその人物はエンジェルっていうのを仕事に
しています
今日は何だ政府もいただけませんどうすりゃいいのか
私は結構テッドを見ているのでまさか自分自
この赤い丸の中に入れるとは思いもしなかったんですけれども
えっと
少なくとも私が今日いらっしゃる皆さんにお伝えできることをお伝えしたいことは何か
ということを絞って絞って考えてきました
それは世界は変えられるって言うことなんですねえ8私という人間が生まれてからどう
してこういう人間になってきたた
そして皆さんに通して世界は変えられるっていい
たいのかということを聞いていただきたいと思いますえっと
その中でこれから話すの中に2つ私人生で誰にも話したことないことが2つあります
聞いてください
8ちょっとノロかなここに私は1950年9月25日に生まれました9月25日今日は
10月6日ですから私現在69歳と11日目を言っています
結構おばあさんなんですそれで
男のところ音と音ら男というふうに私は4番目の子供でした
まぁ全部それでの採用ところとが続いた後の女の子だったので熱心なクリスチャンの母
は神様のお恵みたと言ってとっても喜んで育ててくれました
えっと
兄弟たちはみんな幼児洗礼を受けて私もクリスチャンネームを持っています
珠洲市には小さいけれど祭壇があって貼り付けんだった員様があってマリア像があって
っていうそういう家でした
毎週末教会に行ってお母さんの財布からに常にとりましたとか
友達が悪口言いましたとかいうこと
と言っているようなそういうまあ神様
いるとシンジ君で育っていた私でした
ところがへ何それーと思うようなことが起きました
それは小学校入学式に行って
気を付け
前なら
レゲエ向け右って言われたときにそれが嫌だ
統合ゲームでしたそれはやじゃないですか
通してそんな誰かに言われて迷うん良い右向け右
ない私は左よってこのぐらいそこで私はへそ曲がりな性格は生まれてしまったんだと
思うんですね
だから
がポーンっていうのはやっぱり嫌いでしたね
どうしてもずっと座ってなきゃいけない先生が一方的にしゃべること聞いただけた
ちょっととか
外はに行きたくなってそれはダメ会いしちゃいけない構成きれいな相撲しなさしなさい
それがもういいあるようでしょうかなって
このもに残念のに
today
てはいたんですが蛇毒の記事でもないのでしょ僕はまず卒業しました
中学起きましたいろいろが額から来た友達と一緒になるんですが中学生ともなると同じ
個体と二人ピアになるんですよ値段となく
私をすれば嫌なので誰とペアになったしていたのでいつの一人でした
いつも一人ですかそれでだから友達も出来ないし
5分一人でいて通知表にはだれとでもお友達になりましょうね
協調性を覚えなさいとかと食と書かれていました
でもありがたかったことに
私のハーバーそういうことはあまりしかし彼なかったんですよ
どうしてみんなと同じようにできないのとか先生に言われたとおりにしなさいとかそう
いうふうに私は叱らなかったので私はあのうよう歳ぐらいの時に私で御参り後のつもり
かと言われて
映画書けなくなったんですねで量がこれを a を書かなきゃいけない時あるじゃない
ですか
夏休みに1枚提出しなさいとかそういうこと
お母さんはえーな上手だったので頼んで書いてもらってお母さん来たり書くのは難しい
わねえなんて言うからフィックスって変えて先生は見抜けませんでした
だからあの割と
先生6ことも一人の大人としてその先生だからって盲目的に従うというのはこの人も人
としてどうなるかん作りフィソンな目を持ったずっと名前家の子でもありました
で中学を卒業し高校に入ったんですけれど
もうなんか我慢の限界だと思ってやったりで
ここじゃ
ないどこかに行きたいと思って探していたところ劇団員募集って新聞記事を見つけて
それを受けました
で16歳を演じるしか受けられなかったのであの演技に入っ
受けましたでどうやってたかったので
学校を辞めたいと言って応援を説得してそこに入りました
私にとって夢のような世界でした演劇の舞台の時間ある時間になると客席が真っ暗に
なって
幕が開くと外は現実の世界とは違います
真性だったり未来だったり王様はいたりどれがいたり
今日
様々なシチュエーションで様々な劇的なことが起きるわけですね
私は夢中でした舞台袖の暗闇が大好きでした
ところが連日の三木ダンスの生活という巾着なもので理不尽なもので独裁者が一人入っ
て足6お城これはダメだ
お前たちは演劇の礎に
なんだ切符て号いいというこのぐらいに檄を飛ばされて皆
99と暮らしていました
ちょっと先輩の女性があるときハワイたってしょうがないんだけど
歯医者さんの治療代が高いからハグ治療に行けないって申告に行ってるんですよ
歯の治療はいけないの暮らしって何と思いました
ふと周りを見渡すと結婚している女性1人もいない
子供を産んでいる女性を一人もいないということは私もいずれそうなるのかしらと思っ
て
ちょっとネタ都市の中でまた疑問すか疑問符が出来ました
ん
であるときまあ鍵のようなところで全員を集められてまたそのもっと頑張りとか
チケット売ってこいとかいうことワードその独裁ズっていうのを聞いてるうちに
17で誰かんだしするからだんだんだんだんこいつが悪いこいつ為替というふうに思い
が出てきてしまって
そしたらポロポロポロポロ涙が出て
きてすると隣の人がファラこのひと鳴き出したわよっていける反動になるのでどんどん
私のエキセントリックになってしまいついには思いがほとばしってその局3社が座って
ところに入って新たが悪い
中川べといった打ってしないんですかそれですぐに私は羽交い締めにされて別室に連れ
ていかれました
大勢の劇団員のまでで前で恥をかかされたその独裁者は cg を出しました私はその
2人の人に羽交い絞めにされたままタクシーに乗せられて大きな病院に行きました
そしてなんと
あろうことか電極をつけられて私のノウハウを調べられました
屈辱的でしたでもちろん脳波に異常があるわけなかったんですけれど私は本当に傷つき
ました
神様のもっと活き活きと生きる喜びで育ってきた片言だったんですがそのときに1回
本当に殺されたっていうぐらいに自分の中に膨らんでいたよこれだ
えっ参考になりますか
それでおかしいというラフに押された私は家に帰って父ハンド元に帰って
口ボヒカズご飯も食べずっと異論もんとした時間を過ごしていました
私はどうしても神様に疑問を言いたくなってしまったんですね
である日家の中にはウイスキーを飲んで飲めもしないのにつき良いものです
+らになって祭壇の前で神様り
訪ねました
ポイント維持言うんです
いないんですか
出てくるよは難しいにしても私だけわかる合図でいいから会津をくださいとお願いし
ました
私にだけ風が吹くとか私んだけ雨はパラパラと当たるとかえ願いだから会津下さいお
願いでそう願いですお願いですけど
祈りました
うちは何の塩白ありませんし何の変化も起きませんでした
それで私は何かもう本当に白けた子になってしまって大きく絶望したり挫折したことが
ある方にお分かりだと思いますが
生きていくのもや市沼間やというようなそんな気持ちになってしまいました
でのなんか絶望的な気持ちがうかがえたまま私は自分の未来に戻って
また初々しい有能で
市民や銅のみました
真夜中あの辺だと気が付いた母が私の部屋になってきて
遍歴がついて中堅救急車にうせられる要因に入って私はい洗浄されて助かりました
今こうして生きています
そのことを母は誰にも言わず私に世代
繰り返して言うこともなったから私は記憶の中からその嫌なことをしっかり消し去って
ずっと生きてきました今日初めて人に話しています
でそれからもう私は
調べた子どもながらその時10何歳だったんですけど
しらけた子どもながら人を観察することが大好きになりました
本日は何を頼りにしてるんだろう本当はなんでこんなに自信がんがこいつはなんで
こんなに自信がないんだろうってそういう人を観察することが大好きでいつも壁に
もたれて人を見ているというそれじゃあ斜に構えた女の子でしたところがどういうわけ
か私にお仕事の話が来るんですねそんなに望んでもいなかったと処女言って仕事
積極的にやりたかったわけではないんですがあのなぜか18の時に半年間続くドラマの
テレビ小説の主役に選ばれてあなたがやりなさいと言われました
わからないままにやりました次はこういう仕事ですよつ旅行いバラエティーですよと
言っていつのまにか根っこと言われるものになってレギュラーバージョン本も行って
いる
時期がありましたで浴びじき結婚して忙しいからその結構を破綻してまたなんか普通な
言われるままに成り行きでなーさん瀕してるとか波に乗ってるとか適当なことやでも
適当なチャラい女優でしたその頃本当に
である日私に篭ってるって知ったんですね大資産が
あなたは確かに妊娠してますよって言った時に言われた時に私の中にまた温かいものが
流れてきていける喜びというか命を授かった喜びで本当に
震えるほど嬉しかったです神様ありがとうあと思いました
急いでへと子供のある生活をして優しい夫と子供とまあまあ本当に幸せなん時期を
過ごし
まあ仕事もまあまあやって聴いていました
ところが2011年3月11日です
大きな地震が多くて大きな津波があって減収分発令する大事故があってものすごい人間
が不幸のどん底に落とされました
地震と津波が天才ですけど事故は人災です
防げたんですだと危ない危ないと教えてくれた人たちはいっぱいいたんです
だって日本は広島長崎と原爆のひどい体験をしたじゃないですか
なのに原子力発電をずっと続けてきてチェルノブイリで事故が大きくのにそれでも続い
決定でやっぱり事故が起きたんです
多くて途端に政府は何をしました価格しました
nhk は嘘を言いますテレビも新聞も雑誌も嘘ばっかりです
東大出たような絵ライスが嘘ばっかり言いました see you 的な親友できない
信用できない
自分の命は自分で守らなきゃダメだって言う想い
ニュースは自分で掴んでくるもんだということを覚えました
そしてどんな人は本当のことを言ってるか瞳は犬っていう技の身につけていきたいと
おもいます
だから
私は中卒でほしい
これと言った何の能力もないんですが人を見るだけはあるぞというふうに
アヌン頭痛を持っています
大学を出たような人はたくさんの知識をて
中にいろんな失敗です私は中国で
言ったの誰からもに戻って来なかっ私の鞄がまだまだ空き地がいっぱいなんですね私の
アドバンだか私が知りたいと思ってつかんできたことばっかりが入ってるんですよだ
から結構気に入ってるんですね私は自分の頭の中ってもでまだ空き地があるので私を
学習ぬと呼ばれてるんですよ
携帯ことだけ
me
それはどんどん知ってるともう今69歳でほとんど終わりにかかってるんですがもう
知りたいことだらけでテレビなんか見てるヒマはありませんお笑いで笑ってる場合じゃ
ないんです
そしてもう一つだけ今日&誰に塗ったことになることを話したいと思います
22年前に77歳で死んでしまった私のハハハハリアの親友だった愛ちゃんという人が
お通夜に駆けつけてくれました
政府散々の開いたりした後に愛ちゃんは私に好意ましたところでみどりさんおかあさん
は知能指数5団体に言った
えっ
栄転者言わなかったんだ
話はこういうことです8愛ちゃんと市のハートは同じ年頃の女の子を持っていたので
ある日面白半分に知能指数のテスト2
子どもを連れてったんだそうですで私はすごい高い数字だったんだそうです
ねえ
ブーブー勉強させればいいんじゃないって言ったろすけどねしないから知らない方が
いいっ
私 i
でもはぁからそのことを聞いたことはありませんでしたでこんなことは不瞳に話した
こと鼻一帯もなって私が自分があってもいいなんて一度も思ったことはありません
ところが吸いつい数字つ前に
杏ちゃんの息子さんからはがきが来ましたお母さんがしました
でみどりさんのことフロッキーに入ってたからいつもうつの何歳の緑茶南妻のみどり
さんと書けるようにあなたの人生を見てきましたそれで私が死んだら
みどりちゃんの写真とほんとを入れてねっていう本だったので入れてあげましたって
いうのがありましたそれで起きて三見たときに
あったこともない息子さんなんですけど愛ちゃんのこと私に知らせてくれて
ということは私にとって杏ちゃんの市の斑紋大切な人で本当に大切なことっていうのは
本人に言わない方がいいことになる
死んであの世に持って行ったほうがいいこともあるというねほんとに教育って何だろう
か
学校んということが大切じゃないんですよね学校に行きたくない登校拒否ん
嫌だって言う人も学校2号をやめてくださいろくなことないから
学校じゃないところに行って自分の知りたいことを使うんでつかんでつかんでくれば
いいんですよ
今はインターネット時代ですか
な youtube 大学もあるぐらいですからもし信じたいと思うような人がいた
絶対死なないで世界は変えられるんですあなたが本気であれば私はそう思ってきてい
ます8今日こんな風に素晴らしいところで話をさせてくださってありがとうございます
聞いてくれてありがとうさようなら
[拍手]
me